[Applause]
Shelly was one of the most stable and
prosperous countries in Latin America a
[Applause]
role model a kind of experiment to show
that escaping poverty isn't an
impossible goal even in Latin America
[Music]
however in October 2000 and nineteen
this model seemed to begin to shatter
suddenly waves of extreme violence and
huge political mobilizations erupted it
throughout the country within just a few
weeks the country was on fire since the
protests started 26 people have lost
their lives thousands have been wounded
more than 25,000 premises have been
affected by fires looting or destruction
the Santiago Metro has suffered damage
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and the economy has just stopped to give
you an idea according to government data
the cost of these damages run between
two and three billion dollars
give you up in this video we're gonna
tell you what happened in Chile why it
happened and what lies ahead
[Music]
the spark that lit the fire the October
social explosion was a surprise that
caught everyone off guard the turning
point came when the Chilean government
decided to increase the price of the
Santiago Metro ticket by 30 pesos which
is about four US cents but let's just
say that this was the reason that kind
of sparked that just lit the fire
suddenly hundreds of students began to
protest and during the subway without
paying but it didn't stop there little
by little everything just got out of
hand
we're talking about Monday October the
14th and by Saturday the 19th the subway
was on fire yep on fire half of the city
subway stations had suffered vandalism
attacks and more than 20 of them were
literally ablaze they were being reduced
to ashes
[Music]
to give you an idea just the damages
alone from Saturday the 19th cost an
estimated 200 million dollars and yura
announces a state of emergency in Chile
after an intense explosion of violence
due to the rise in subway rates but
that's was only the beginning in the
following days the situation got even
worse and protests spread to the rest of
the country
[Music]
suddenly supermarkets shops buses even
entire buildings were being vandalized
and looted chili no longer looks like
the chili it once was tremendously
radicalized groups wanted to end the
so-called Chilean model with a
revolution
of course as he can imagine the police
didn't tiptoe around this issue they
responded swiftly and with an iron fist
that's one thing on which major human
rights organizations agree reports
ranging from the United Nations High
Commissioner for Human Rights to
organizations such as Human Rights Watch
have exposed a collection of evidence
which proves that in many cases the
Chilean security forces the carabiniere
o--'s used excessive force
according to data from the Ministry of
Health the emergency services can for
more than 11,500 people as a result of
the demonstrations of those casualties
1100 so far it presented moderate to
severe injuries and that's not all there
have been more than 350 complaints about
ill-treatment torture and abuse of
detainees factors such as the
indiscriminate and improper use of riot
guns and shotguns abuses against
detainees and poor internal control
systems facilitated serious rights
violations from many Chileans Jose
Miguel vivanco director of the Human
Rights Watch of the Americas protests in
Chile UN report reiterates that there
has been a quote high number of serious
human rights violations in any case just
to be clear there are two very important
details we have to consider
[Music]
first we do not aim to condone acts of
violence not at all
quite the opposite these radical violent
aggressive groups that deserve all our
condemnation had no reservations when
they attacked the police with stones
benches and anything they could get
their hands on even Molotov cocktails
not to mention the looting theft
intimidation etc they have also been
victims of these acts of violence in
fact today we have more than 2500
injured police officers some of them
quite seriously Sebastien Kenyatta
President of Chile on the other hand
most protesters behaved peacefully and
many suffered the consequences of a
police force that was simply not
prepared for what came chill a urgent
call for police reform after protests
excessive use of force against
protesters and bystanders serious abuses
during detention because don't think
that the protests in Chile were the work
of a few radicals not at all October the
25th will go down in Chile's history
eleven days after the riots broke out
according to official statistics 1.2
million people took to the streets to
protest against the country's situation
and to show their discontent with the
path the country was taking the crowd
equators to more than 20% of Santiago's
population
so at this point we need to ask
ourselves our protests of this kind
really justified in Latin America's most
prosperous country well I can already
tell you that it's a very touchy subject
chili soup a denim patrimonio sanitary
ou K no Sakata mucho Conchita aqui
tenemos que coud our camuto reward que
no permit a sarin probe Lord alimentos
seguros Asano's parle Gretel moon
tenemos tratado de Libre comercio con la
principales economy Aden how Chile has
changed in 30 years
let's know with the positives
it's not 30 pesos it's 30 years this has
been one of the main protest slogans
that little by little have been
justified by the high inequality that
Chileans have suffered as a results of
the system that has prevailed in the
last three decades but the question is
has this period really been so that and
the truth is know for example take a
look at how poverty has changed
jenny has evolved from being one of the
poorest countries in Latin America to
fighting for the number one spot amongst
the richest and most developed in facts
if we check out the Human Development
Index which in addition to economic
variables includes things such as health
care education and life expectancy Chile
is top in the region
regarding inequality Chile truly has a
lot of inequality but it isn't true that
it's worst off in this matter in Latin
America not at all in fact
what's more is one of the few countries
in the region where inequality has
decreased the most in recent years and
this isn't just my opinion or visual
politics opinion this is coming straight
from the data because if instead of
looking at inequality overall we focus
on the inequality levels between people
of the same age we'll see much lower
rates of inequality among the younger
generations this also happens with
education if we look at the whole
country will find that in Chile the
percentage of the population with
secondary education is lower than the
OECD average
that's if we take a look at Chileans
aged between 25 and 34 we'll see that
they are already surpassing the average
of the richest countries and this isn't
unusual it's a very common feature in
countries that have grown very rapidly
it's easy to find different
characteristics within a single
population based on the generation one
part will of grown Arvin's lived in a
poor country and the next in a developed
country
but that's the best way to approach this
mess is that taken by rodrigo valdez
finance minister rim michelle bachelet
second term we're not talking about a
radical libertarian in 2018 this man
presented an article at the Harvard
Kennedy School where he stated two
things first that the left was making
mistakes left and right by focusing so
much on the issue of inequality because
to combat it economic growth was much
more important than redistribution from
seconds that's in the last 30 years
those who'd seen their income increased
the most was precisely those who had
previously been the poorest check this
out in other words what the country
needed above all was more economic
growth and that growth has been somewhat
to blame for Chile's current problems
because as I said it's an extremely
touchy situation so do Chileans really
have reasons to complain well listen up
the root of disappointment
the fact that many things have gone well
doesn't mean that Chileans have no
reason to feel disappointed and
disappointed really is the word for it
Chileans were promised results that
never happens despite everything we've
seen some things just aren't so positive
for example the country has a very low
productivity level that continues to
hamper wages for than 60 percent of the
entire middle-class population live on
the edge they're vulnerable to losing
that level for even the smallest reason
and the economy another of Chile's great
points of pride in the past has
practically stagnated at least nots in
per capita terms performance in recent
years has been quite poor
[Music]
and of course if there's no economic
growth and real wages don't increase
well things don't look so rosy right and
not just that retirement pensions
another of the great promises Chileans
were made very low it's give you an idea
half of the pensions paid in recent
months amounted to only one hundred and
twenty three thousand pesos that's about
a hundred and sixty dollars a month it's
quite a miserable amount and that's not
to say that Chile's capitalization
pension system is bad not at all really
what's happening is that citizens don't
really know how it works because it's
never been properly explained to them on
top of that the government hasn't been
paying close enough attention you see on
the one hand they didn't monitor whether
the total contributions over a working
life were adequate and on the other
hands they never bothered to establish a
minimum safety nets for those who
wouldn't managed to contribute enough
this combination is volatile because
people are right off a reasonably good
system because the pensions they reports
are very very low
[Music]
this means the system becomes a ticking
time bomb as more and more citizens hit
retirement age clan men retire at 65
with just 18 years of contributions on
average and for women it's even worse
they retire at 60 with an average of 13
years of contributions
so what have they been doing for the
rest of their working lives well in
formal economy casual work under the
table agreements that they didn't
declare and things like that and
consider that how can you hope to
support 20 or 30 years of retirement if
you've only contributed 10 percent of
your salary for 13 15 or 18 years it's
impossible it's just impossible to pay
higher pensions if people don't
accurately declare their earnings the
system simply doesn't work not one way
not another way it just doesn't work and
if to all of this we add the feeling
that social divisions are still very
present within society we can understand
the enormous frustration that fuels the
protests although if we think about it
for a second it seems a little unfair to
focus the discontent on a president who
want the elections very recently what's
more for the almost 30 years of chile's
democracy the Left rules for almost 25
and they're the ones who were protesting
I mean they must have had a hand in
establishing the model don't you think
[Music]
basically expectations are just not
being met and in a way this can be
explains with what is known as Wagner's
law a thesis that states that the
greater the wealth the greater the
pressures for the state to provide more
and more social benefits and of course
the smaller the state a stronger this
dynamic is going to be and now the
question is or what's next
[Music]
the lights at the end of the tunnel
I think we can now understand much
better what has recently been happening
in Chile the question is well this
problem ends panera president piñera is
doing two things
on the one hand he's launching a social
agenda that among many other issues will
increase the lowest pensions and
establish a minimum wage that is the
government will top up the payrolls of
people who don't work and don't reach
three hundred and fifty thousand pesos
[Music]
on the other hands it has been agreed
that in 2020 Chileans will be asked if
they want to change their constitution
even though the Chilean Constitution has
already undergone 219 changes since the
democratic transition occurred the last
significant one happened in 2005 this is
a very big day for Chile we have a
reason to celebrate today we finally
have a democratic constitution in line
with the spirit of Chile Ricardo Lagos
President of Chile from 2000 to 2006
well he was wrong because apparently
it's no longer useful and what can I say
beyond the fact that it isn't advisable
to change the Constitution often nor
generate false expectations what surely
needs to focus on is growth only then
can it truly overcome all of the
problems it faces anyway I hope that you
found this video interesting I hope it
helped you understand what's recently
been happening in the South American
country we'll be paying close attention
to see how the events unfold and I
really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe a
brand new videos also please do check
our friends at the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine also this
channel is possible because of patreon
and our patrons on that platform please
do consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]